so that's
p and and p but the complexity zoo is
full of
wonderful creatures well it's got about
500 of them 500.
so how do you get uh yeah
yeah how do you get more how do you yeah
yeah well okay i mean i mean
i mean just for starters there is
everything that we could do
with a conventional computer with a
polynomial amount of memory
okay but possibly an exponential amount
of time because we get to reuse the same
memory over and over again
okay that is called p space okay and
that's actually a
we think an even larger class than np
okay well
p is contained in np which is contained
in p space
and we think that those containments are
strict and the
the constraint there is on the memory
the memory has to grow
polynomially with the size of the that's
right that's right
but in p space we now have interesting
things that were not
in in np like uh as a famous example
you know from a given position in chess
you know does white or black have the
win
let's say assuming provided that the
game lasts only for a reasonable number
of moves
okay or or or likewise for go okay and
then
you know even for the generalizations of
these games to arbitrary size boards
because with an 8x8 board you could say
that's just a constant size problem you
just
you know in principle you just solve it
in o of one time right but
so we really mean the uh the
generalizations of of
you know games to uh arbitrary size
boards here
or um another thing in p space would be
uh
like i give you some really hard um
constraint satisfaction problem
like you know uh you know traveling
salesperson or uh
you know packing boxes into the trunk of
your car or something like that
and i asked not just is there a solution
which would be an np
problem but i ask how many solutions are
there okay
that you know count the number of of of
solute of valid solutions
that that that actually gives those
problems
lie in a complexity class called sharp p
or
like it looks like like hashtag p
okay which sits between np and p space
um there's all the problems that you can
do in exponential time
okay that's called x so um
and by the way uh it it was proven in
the 60s
that x is larger than p okay so we know
that much
we know that there are problems that are
solvable in exponential time
that are not solvable in polynomial time
okay
in fact we even know more we know that
there are problems that are solvable in
n
cubed time that are not solvable in n
squared time
and that those don't help us with a
controversy between pnm
unfortunately it seems not or certainly
not yet
right the uh the the the techniques that
we use to establish those things
they're very very related to how touring
proved the unsolvability of the halting
problem
but they seem to break down when we're
comparing two different
resources like time versus space or like
you know p
versus np okay but you know i mean
there's
there's what you can do with a
randomized algorithm right that can
sometimes
you know with some has some probability
of making a mistake
that's called bpp bounded error
probabilistic polynomial time
and then of course there's one that's
very close to my own heart
what you can efficiently do do in
polynomial time using a quantum computer
okay and that's called bqp right and so
you know what's understood about that
class so
p is contained in bpp which is contained
in bqp
which is contained in p space okay so
anything you can
in fact in in like in something very
similar to sharp p
bqp is basically you know well it's
contained in like
p with the magic power to solve sharp p
problems
okay why why is bqp contained in uh
p space oh that's an excellent question
uh so uh there there is um well i mean
one one has to prove that okay
but uh the proof um uh you could you
could think of it as uh
using uh richard feynman's picture of
quantum mechanics
which is that you can always you know we
haven't really talked about
uh quantum mechanics in this in this
conversation we we did in our previous
yeah
yeah we did last time but yeah we did
last time okay but uh
uh but basically you could always think
of a quantum computation
as uh like a branching tree of
possibilities
where each pos each possible path that
you could take
through you know your the space has a
complex number attached to it called an
amplitude
okay and now the rule is you know when
you make a measurement at the end
will you see a random answer okay but
quantum mechanics is all about
calculating the probability that you're
going to see one
potential answer versus another one
right and the rule for calculating
the probability that you'll see some
answer is that you have to add up the
amplitudes for
all of the paths that could have led to
that answer
and then you know that's a complex
number so that you know
how could that be a probability then you
take the squared absolute value of the
result
that gives you a number between zero and
one okay
so um yeah i just i just summarized
quantum mechanics in like 30 seconds
okay but uh but now you know what what
this already tells us is
that anything i can do with a quantum
computer i could simulate with a
classical computer
if i only have exponentially more time
okay and why is that
because if i have exponential time i
could just
write down this entire branching tree
and just
explicitly calculate each of these
amplitudes
right you know that will be very
inefficient but it will work
right it's enough to show that quantum
computers could not
solve the halting problem or you know
they could never do anything that is
literally uncomputable
in touring sense okay but now as i said
there is even a stronger result
which says that bqp is contained in p
space
the way that we prove that is that we
say if
if all i want is to calculate the
probability
of some particular output happening we
know which is all i need to simulate a
quantum computer really
then i don't need to write down the
entire quantum state
which is an exponentially large object
all i need to do
is just calculate what is the amplitude
for that final state
and to do that i just have to sum up
all the amplitudes that lead to that
state okay so that's an
exponentially large sum but i can
calculate it just reusing the same
memory
over and over for each term in the song
hence the p
in the pieces yeah yeah so what uh
out of that whole complexity zoo and it
could be bqp what do you find is the
most
uh uh the class that captured your heart
the most
is the most beautiful class there's just
yeah
i i used uh as my email address uh
bqpqpali at gmail.com
just because uh bqp slash q poly
well you know amazingly no one had taken
it amazing
but you know but th this is a class that
i was involved in sort of uh defining
proving the first theorems about uh in
2003 or so
so it was kind of close to my heart uh
but this is like if we extended
um bqp which is the class of everything
we can do efficiently with a quantum
computer
uh to allow quantum advice which means
imagine that you had some
special initial state okay that could
somehow help you
do computation and maybe um
such a state would be exponentially hard
to prepare
okay but you know maybe somehow these
states were formed in the big bang or
something and they've just been sitting
around ever since right if you found one
and if this state could be like ultra
power there are no limits on how
powerful it could be
except that this state doesn't know in
advance which input you've got
right it only knows the size of your
input you know and then
that that's bqp slash q probably so
that's that's one that i just personally
happen to love
okay but um you know if you're asking
like what's the
you know there's a there's a class that
i think is is
is way more beautiful than you know or
fundamental
then a lot of people even within this
this field
realize that it is that class is called
sck
or statistical zero knowledge um
and you know there's a very very easy
way to define this class
which is to say suppose that i have two
algorithms
that each sample from probability
distributions
right so each one just outputs random
samples
according to you know possibly different
distributions and now
the question i ask is you know you know
let's say distributions over strings of
n bits
yeah so over an exponentially large
space now i ask
are these two distributions close or far
as probability distributions okay any
problem that can be reduced to that
you know that can be put into that form
is an sdk
problem and the way that this class was
originally discovered was completely
different from that
and was kind of more complicated it was
discovered as the class of
all of the problems that have a certain
kind of what's called zero knowledge
proof
zero knowledge proofs are one of the
central ideas in cryptography
um you know shafi goldwasser and silvio
mccauley won the touring award
for you know inventing them and they're
at the core of even some some
cryptocurrencies
that you know people people use nowadays
but um are zero knowledge proofs or ways
of proving to someone that something is
true
like you know that there is a uh a
solution to this
you know uh optimization problem or that
these two graphs
are isomorphic to each other or
something but without revealing why it's
true
without revealing anything about why
it's true
okay sdk is all of the problems
for which there is such a proof uh that
doesn't rely on any cryptography
okay and if if you wonder like how could
such a thing possibly exist
right well like imagine that i had two
graphs and i wanted to convince you that
these two graphs are not isomorphic
meaning you know i cannot permute one of
them so that it's the same as the other
one
right you know that might be a very hard
statement to prove like i might need you
know
you might have to do a very exhaustive
enumeration of you know all the
different
permutations before you were convinced
that it was true but what if there were
some
all-knowing wizard that said to you look
i'll tell you what
just pick one of the graphs randomly
then randomly permute it
then send it to me and i will tell you
which graph you started with
okay and i will do that every single
time
right and let's load that in okay that's
what got it yeah and
and let's say that that wizard did that
a hundred times and it was right every
time
yeah right now if the graphs were
isomorphic then you know it would have
been flipping a coin each time
right it would have had only a one and
two to the 100 power chance of
you know of guessing right each time but
you know so so if it's right every time
then now you're statistically convinced
that these graphs are not isomorphic
even though you've learned nothing new
about why they aren't so fascinating so
yeah so so sdk is
all of the problems that have protocols
like that one
but it has this beautiful other
characterization it's shown up again and
again in my in my own work in you know a
lot of people's work
and i think that it really is one of the
most fundamental classes
it's just that people didn't realize
that when it was first discovered
you